thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the micro Cosmos
the first 1000 people to click on the
link in the description can get a one
month free trial of skillshare's Premium
membership
[Music]
our oceans and lakes are filled with
copepods a myriad of small crustacean
species that might float as Plankton or
infect other creatures and as they're
living in whatever manner best suits
them some copepods like our friend here
become more than just their own creature
they become a surface a place for
someone else or something else to settle
down upon
[Music]
in the case of this copepod the
residents that have taken root on its
carapace are many many ciliates they're
single-celled bodies accumulating into a
microscopic bouquet and before we get
into the specifics of what's going on
with this meeting of crustacean in
ciliate I want to ask you a quick
question don't overthink it just go with
your gut instinct who would you rather
be in this scenario the copepod or the
ciliate
now I promise you there's no right
answer to this question it's just
something that's interesting to think
about whenever we peer into the
microcosmos and see creatures with
habits that seem quite different to our
own though we should note that we do
have some things in common with the
microcosmos in this context our skin is
covered with its own array of microbes
an invisible community of bacteria and
fungi and other creatures that affect
the way our bodies interact with the
world around us so if you were asked who
you would rather be a human or a microbe
living on a human we would not blame you
at all if you stuck with what's familiar
and instinctively went with a human
being please but the microbiome on our
skin has a different experience than say
these silliest growing on a rotifer for
one they spend their lives in water
which means they have a completely
different environment shaping their
needs and microbial relationships plus
they are a whole lot smaller than us so
that's where we are going to focus today
what happens when one tiny creature
decides to live on another tiny creature
there's a name for this kind of
relationship epibiosis and it's not
limited to the microcosmos or to water
environments it might help to think of
it as the flip side of another
relationship we've watched play out in
the micro Cosmos
endosymbiosis where one creature decides
to live on the inside of another one
like these algae growing inside of a
Hydra but the relationship between
endosymbionts and their host can look
different depending on the species but
in cases like these it might be the host
providing shelter in the form of their
bodies in exchange for nutrients made by
their endosymbiont in contrast epibiosis
is when one creature decides to live on
the outside of another one and sometimes
epibiosis is super obvious like it was
with the copepod that we started out
with but take a look at this dynamoeba
this organism was first described by the
American naturalist Joseph Lighty in the
19th century and from a distance it
doesn't seem like the dynamoeba has much
going on there's certainly no ornate
flowery growths protruding from it but
when you zoom in you can see all sorts
of bacteria and archaea arranged on its
surface in this case those bacteria and
Archaea are epibions which is the name
that we give to organisms growing on top
of another organism and the dynamoeba is
the base of ion the organism that the
epibience are growing upon and in the
microcosmos sometimes you are the basal
biont and other times you are the
epibiont this leafy ciliate zuthamnium
for example can be found growing on
copepods similar to how we found our
ciliates in the beginning of this video
but we've also found zuthamnium with
euglenoids growing on them like their
green sprinkles that stay glued to their
stalks and we've even seen strange sites
like these prokaryotes growing on top of
a larger prokaryote although we are not
sure what species they are or what they
might be getting out of this nearness to
one another and given the diversity in
epibience the way that they attach
themselves to the base of ion varies a
lot as well
for the smallest microbes their path
towards their new Surface is shaped by
the viscous forces around them that
creates a wall of water they have to
break through before they can latch onto
their new home and for unicellular
eukaryotes or even multicellular ones
the decision to attach itself to another
creature might just be another part of a
longer life cycle a shift from a free
swimming self that ages into something
willing to settle down using an adhesive
molecule to glue them together and if
you are the basa biont welcoming these
epibience might actually work out well
for you these new residents might
provide you with some nutrition that you
are lacking supplying metabolic
byproducts that are now in very close
proximity these epibions might even help
you hide from predators masking the
chemical cues that give your location
away but there are trade-offs as well
for one you are literally shouldering
the weight of other organisms in one
water that can make all the difference
affecting your speed and buoyancy and
epibions can even get in the way of
important needs blocking off sun or
impeding reproductive organs from their
usual functions meanwhile for the
epibayant there are pros and cons as
well life on another creature means that
you've got free Transportation wherever
your vasobiont chooses to go and these
surfaces often make for great places to
grab the remains of whatever your
bazobiont is eating but life is also
unstable on a living surface when your
basal biont grows or sheds or
experiences some other major life change
you the epibiont will find the very
ground beneath you changing as well
there's this disadvantage inherent to
both the epibiant and basal biond life
in one paper we found the term they used
was shared Doom which is a more poetic
way to say this if they get eaten you
get eaten too and it is a strange
consequence to think about that this
partnership makes its individuals
vulnerable to new threats the basabiant
now faces the epibions Predators and
vice versa as their identities have
co-mingled and blurred together and yet
they are still two distinct entities one
lived upon the other living upon so ask
the question again which would you
rather be the epibiont or the basaviant
or maybe there is little difference
between the two each shaped by the whims
of the other because ultimately in some
way every organism on Earth it has to be
said is both lived upon and lives upon
just as we are shaped by the microbes on
our skin and the Earth under our feet
but next week we're gonna focus on one
case of ebibiosis where we think the
answer is perhaps a bit cleaner
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and we'd also like to
say thank you to skillshare for
supporting this video you can learn a
lot on skillshare from gardening to
cooking or illustration you can learn
how to script shoot and edit your own
YouTube videos from one of the most
successful creators on the platform
Marquez Brownlee drawing on a decade of
experience Marquez opens up his process
like never before guiding you step by
step through every stage of content
creation from scripting and
storyboarding to shooting and editing
you'll learn how to create videos that
connect whether you have one follower or
one hundred thousand skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for anyone who
loves learning and wants to explore
their creativity and learning skills
with so much to explore and real world
projects to create skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused on
leveling up your skills if you're one of
the first thousand people to click on
the link in the description you can get
a one month free trial of skillshare's
Premium membership
and speaking of organisms relying on
other organisms these are our patreon
patrons they are the people who make it
possible to make the thing that we make
thank you so much to all of them for
being a part of what we do it is a
pretty small percentage of the folks who
watch who make it possible for everyone
to enjoy what we do here at Journey to
the micro Cosmos so if you want to join
me in feeling grateful to them right now
I very much appreciate it and if you
would like to join them you can find us
at patreon.com journey to micro if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign